That is the name of the main hall of the museum, containing mural paintings telling us the
glorious victory which lasted for 25 years under Skanderbeg's leadership.
The mural paintings are recounting for the following events.
After the Battle of Nish, November 3, 1443, Skanderbeg together with 300 Albanian northern
horsemen returned in Kruja where on November 28, 1443, the red Albanian flag with the double-headed
eagle was risen.
In the painting, our national hero is presented knelt before his mother and a swell as a part
of his speech held in front of the people of Kruja saying,
I was not the one who brought you freedom, I found it here among you.
The unification under the leadership of Skanderbeg was decided in Leja.
Here one can find displayed also the flags of the main princedoms, castriots, skorais,
The mural painting in the center of the room is featuring fragments from the Albanian-Ottoman
Wars.
This painting is the biggest in our country, about 108 square meters and contains 300 characters.
The author of this gigantic painting is Najib Akali, who worked for about 11 and half months.
In the same room are exhibited the sword and spiky helmet of Skanderbeg, the original are
in Vienna Museum of Arms.
For 25 years Skanderbeg fought over 20 battles.
The most prominent ones are the Third Kruja Sieges in 1450, in 1466 and in 1467, the Battle
of Torvjali in 1444, the Battle of Albulin in 1457, and the Battle of Vaikali in 1465.
This painting shows the last moments of Skanderbeg's life.
Here are presented the tearful warriors and at the same time unified.
Skanderbeg died in Leja on January 17 in 1467.
With his activity, Skanderbeg takes the most important place in Albanian history and he
is our national hero.
In alabaster are shown some of the main fortresses from the Middle Ages, Barati, Petrela, Rodon
and the fortress of Kruja.
In the map is shown a wider distribution of the fortifications while the engravings on
the side are demonstrating moments from the four battles.
The engraving on glass features the First Kruja Siege by the Ottomans in 1450.